[Music]
it's hard being the middle child and
it's even harder having ten siblings
well it's a lot better than 25 siblings
don't get it keep on watching because
we'll explain why Lincoln is the only
member of the loud family with white
hair don't forget to hit that
notification bell to never miss another
video and be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun now
let's dive deeper into Lincoln Louds
hair
the loud house gang is definitely an
interesting Bunch with the only boy in
the family
Lincoln loud being put directly in the
middle this of course comes with a lot
of consequences that make good
storylines but they also make us feel
terrible for Lincoln the way Lincoln
gets treated is sometimes completely
unfair and it really makes things
slightly uncomfortable to watch how do
you play that I punch EU every time I
see a car but if you want to know more
about that
be able to watch some of our other loud
house videos sometimes Lincoln really
gets the short end of the stick doesn't
he speaking of short have you ever
really paid attention to Lincoln's hair
it's easily miscible due to the strong
personalities and fashion choices of his
sisters I can't wait to put it on my
fashion blog but the truth is Lincoln is
the only member of the loud house family
with white hair it's quite unusual
considering he's definitely not old
enough to have any white strands of hair
showing anywhere could it be that the
white hair comes from the fact that he's
under so much stress we know that living
with so many sisters isn't easy and
Lincoln pretty much takes care of them
by himself sure his parents are there
but we all know how cartoon parents are
his loud house life is literally causing
him so much stress he has white hair
jk jk there's actually a real reason
behind Lincoln's hair although it hasn't
really been confirmed fans came to this
conclusion because it just seems like
the most sensible explanation ever so
what's the truth
well if you're a loud house super fan
you probably already know this but for
all of those that aren't brace
yourselves
the truth is Lincoln and the rest of his
loud house sisters we're actually
rabbits in the original version of the
show it's pretty crazy to think that we
could have gotten rabbit characters
instead of the human ones
and guess what those rabbits actually
appeared in an episode of the loud house
the episode can be found in the third
season of the show
and it's called white hair the episode
is all about Lincoln imagining what it
would be like to have even more sisters
and so he gets turned into a rabbit this
idea was originally created by Chris
Savino who was the show's head director
the white hair episode was also one of
the few episodes he wrote himself and
that's because it goes back to his
original idea of having a cartoon of a
boy rabbit with 25 sisters of course the
idea behind so many rabbit siblings came
from the fact that rabbits multiply and
Chris also has a large family himself
and many of his sisters names as well as
names of the rest of the family and pets
make it into the show but we can thank
nickelodeon for intervening at the early
stages of Chris's pitch and making him
change the rabbits into actual humans
Chris said that everything started to
fall into place when that change was
made and the number was reduced from 25
to just 10 sisters if you think about it
it would have been extremely hard to
create personalities for 25 sisters and
feature all of them in a single episode
that's a lot of work and obviously this
worked out much better it just shows
that if you're willing to work on your
ideas after getting feedback you can
make your ideas great we seriously can't
imagine the loud house storyline as
rabbits so now you know that the loud
house characters were meant to be
rabbits let's look at Lincoln in more
detail
he does have some distinctive features
that could compare him to a rabbit of
course there's his white hair which is
clearly a tribute to his rabbit days but
if you look closely you'll notice that
Lincoln's rabbit version also has
extremely similar teeth Lincoln's
real-life human tooth is actually
chipped it's not certain whether this
was made on purpose to distinguish the
human character from the rabbit but
we're pretty sure it was or maybe is
chipped tooth has its own individual
story and there's another reason behind
but the bottom line is there's clear
correlation between the rabbits and
Lincoln's white hair after all no other
loud house sibling has the same hair it
would also seem fitting that the main
character would carry a tribute to the
original rabbit characters right in
Lincoln's case it's definitely his hair
and his teeth it is so adorable and we
love how it's making him stand out but
his hair and teeth isn't the only thing
that connects link into his past rabbit
life did you know that rabbits are
characterized as me
we tame and modest animals they're not
really hyper are they and they
definitely don't have the same ability
to move around as some of the others
they're pretty chill and they're the
happiest when they're totally relaxed we
all know Lincoln's the happiest when he
can play his video games Wow feels like
it was built for me but his personality
is also a pretty tame and chill isn't it
of course this correlation wasn't
confirmed we feel like his personality
also has a lot to do with rabbits
really rabbits don't have any negative
traits right and neither does Lincoln
Lincoln's pretty unique and he
definitely has a lot on his plate we
can't even imagine dealing with the
things he has to deal with at his age it
is definitely building his character
isn't it some loud house fans love this
but some also really hate it and think
he's just a very bland character ouch
pretty harsh what do you think come
share your thoughts in the comments
below and that's it for our video don't
forget to subscribe to the things for
more videos like this one
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]
[Music]